this video is brought to you by glasses
USA more about them in a bit but if you
want glasses is not 70% off retail
follow the glasses USA link in the
description
you'll love it although give you your
money back and let's get into it
Mohandas Gandhi started out as a scared
painfully young man yet he was
transformed by injustice to step beyond
his insecurities to become the 20th
century's most influential champion of
social justice and the standard bearer
for nonviolent resistance his example of
humility courage and quiet dignity has
inspired millions and been the catalyst
for the change to a better world
in this week's by graphics we discover
the inspirational story of the great
soul Mahatma Gandhi
[Music]
Mohandas Karamchand Gandhi was born on
October the 2nd 1869 in the coastal
Indian town of poor Banda he was the
youngest of six children which included
two half-sisters from his father's
previous marriage montez's father calm
Chand was the deewan or political leader
of Banda his mother but li Bai was
deeply religious impressing strong Hindu
beliefs on her children quran chants
provided well for his family who lived
in a three-story house and had servants
laundress was known by all as Mohan he
was especially devoted to his mother who
he considered to be a saint her piety
made a deep impression upon him when the
boy was 5 his father was appointed the
chief minister of the smaller inland
city of ratch court after two years the
family joined him there Bowen was a
painfully shy child who kept to himself
at school when his lessons were done he
would run home in order to avoid having
to talk to any of his peers he was also
a fearful child he was terrified of many
things but especially the dark he found
his only at solace in books which were
something of a constant companion when
he was just seven years of age s was the
Hindu custom Mahad became engaged to
Kasturba Mohanji Kapadia who was a few
months older than him the arranged
marriage was completed when Mohan turned
13 the planning for the knavish wedding
ceremony and adjustment to married life
meant that he had to take a year off
from his schooling he was an average
student at best though he tried hard to
please his teachers he had no interest
in sports games or social activities
with any of his peers he did however
make one friend around this time he was
a Muslim boy by the name of Shaikh matam
Sheikh was all Durin's more street smart
than Mohan he was also physically larger
and stronger than him he tried in Mohan
about his frail condition and told him
that if he ate meat he would get much
bigger and stronger now this was
strictly against the Hindu beliefs but
Mohan met his friend in secret one day
and he had his first taste of meat even
though they caused him to vomit he
continued to eat it for the next year
without letting anyone else know during
that period Shaikh took him to a brothel
and experian
which was an embarrassing disaster for
the impressionable team realizing that
shake was a bit of a bad influence e
cutoff association with him and returned
to a strict vegetarian diet
Bowens father kam Chong's died when the
boy was 16 years old the grief was
compounded when Marne and Kasturba spher
child died less than a week old the
couple would go on to have four more
children with the first being born in
no one completed college at the age of
18 and enrolled in some modest college
however he disliked the lecture style of
teaching and dropped out after only a
few months he had set his sights on
becoming a lawyer and eventually
becoming a Diwan like his father the
family friend suggested that he should
go to England to study where it was
easier to pass the bar it was agreed
that this would be the best course for
the shy Hindu boy was now headed for the
bright lights of London on August the
10th 1888 maan left his family including
his wife and his one-month old son
Harilal and he headed for Bombay where
he boarded a ship that was bound for
London before leaving though he was
summoned by the leader of his caste who
warns him that if he went to England he
would be tempted to break the rules of
Hinduism he was told to either abandon
his plans or be excommunicated from the
caste
Gandhi accepted this consequence and he
continued upon his way fitting into
Western culture though it was a it was a
shock to the 18-year old everything it
was so different what he had known back
in India still he did his best to fit in
buying a fine suit complete with leather
gloves top hat and silver tips cane he
also paid for lessons in elocution
manners and dance his biggest challenge
was with regard to his diet he had vowed
to his mother that he was not going to
eat meat but he was finding it very
difficult to find restaurants that
catered to vegetarians his chronic
shiners prevented him from requesting
alternatives to what was on offer
finally though he found a vegetarian
restaurant along with a whole community
of vegetarians and it was at this point
that he joins the London vegetarian
society despite his difficulties with
fitting into London life Gandhi did well
academically he passed his lore exams in
June of 1891 his friends at the
vegetarian society they held a
celebratory evening in his
when it came time to give a speech
however Mohan was so nervous that he
simply rose and only said thank you on
his return to India Mohan was met at
Bombay harbour by his older brother who
bought some terrible news his mother but
li Bai had died in his absence
moans grief was compounded with the
consequences of his overseas for a he
was now disfellowshipped from his caste
in order to please his family members he
agreed to bathe in a sacred River in
order to wash away the sins of England
this precipitated his re-entry into the
caste Gandhi looked for work as a lawyer
in Bombay however his chronic shyness
was still preventing him from making any
advancement he recalls how he felt
presenting his first case before the
court saying my head was reeling and it
felt as if the whole court was doing
likewise he retreated to the less
imposing town of rajkot and established
a small law office there shortly
thereafter he received an offer from a
merchant who had been a friend of his
father this man was now based in South
Africa and he needed a lawyer to help
with a court case the year-long job was
offered to Gandhi and he accepted her
too despite recently becoming a father
again he kept his wife and two young
sons under the care of his brother and
he headed off the Durban South Africa in
April of 1893 after settling into his
new surroundings Gandhi took the trains
Pretoria where the court case was to be
tried he purchased a first-class ticket
however on one of the stops the European
man boarded the car that he was in the
man resented seeing an Indian in first
class and left to find the train
conductor the two men returned and
Gandhi was ordered to go down to the
third-class section Gandhi showed them
his first-class ticket and refused to
move after that train security was
called and Gandhi was kicked off the
train he had to go the rest of the way
in a horse-drawn carriage however the
white passengers of their carriage they
refused to let an Indian sit inside with
them and he was made to sit on the
outside footboard
he later recalls the insult was more
than I could bear this was the watershed
experience of mahon dress Gandhi's life
as if by miracle he shook off his timid
nature and stepped forward as a leader
of the oppressed when he arrived in
Pretoria he called a meeting of the
Indian community and gave the
speech of his life calling for the
Indians to stand up for their rights
once his work on the court case was
complete Gandhi decided to stay and
continue to fight for Indian rights in
1894 he established the natal Indian
Congress to give Indians a political
voice he established himself as a leader
in the local community giving free legal
advice and offering support in 1896
after three years in South Africa Gandhi
returned to India to collect his family
he returned with his wife and two sons
who were now aged nine and five along
with a nephew Gandhi demanded that his
family dresses Europeans and eat with
knives and forks as was the way with
Indians in South Africa this caused
tension within his family still two more
songs were added to the family in the
coming years when the burr war broke out
in 1899 Gandhi fell to that if the
Indian supported the government they
would be rewarded with that a treatment
he organised an Indian ambulance corps
who were a valuable asset to the army
but the loyalty it went unrewarded with
the harsh treatment continuing during
this time Gandhi develops the life
philosophy which was to guide him for
the remainder of his days he called it
satyagraha which means devotion to the
truth the three core tenets of the
belief were non-cooperation non-violence
and non-possession in 1906 the South
African province of Transvaal enacted a
law that required all Indians to
register and be given identity cards the
police were allowed to stop and demand
their registration at any time no other
group had this requirement Gandhi
advocated the use of satyagraha to
counter the law he told people not to
register as a result he and many others
were thrown in jail but Gandhi taught
that righteous imprisonment was an
honorable thing the concept of
satyagraha took hold and Gandhi
established a number of cetera
settlements the people in these
settlements they practiced
non-possession living a simple and
austere life Gandhi also organized a
large coal miners strike the men
practiced non-cooperation by refusing to
work and non-violence by refusing to
react when they were attacked by
authorities in July of 1940 in the South
African government passed the Indian
Relief Act which went some way to
righting the wrongs that had been heaped
upon the Indian community the 20 years
of struggle that Gandhi had put in
the cause were largely responsible for
these changes and after this he was
ready to return to India bringing his
philosophy with him and you know what
else he brought back to India with him
his famous glasses yes I absolutely just
did that welcome to an unexpected abri
brought to you by glasses USA and you
can bet that Gandhi wish they existed
back when he wore glasses because
they're just excellent these ones
they're called Elias and I've also got
two others that you see me wearing from
time to time there's one this there's
also a bigger pair which I don't have on
my little table here but you can also
get them in a whole bunch of other stars
they've got a huge range some four
thousand options are available and hey
they've also got designer sunglasses you
saw me wearing these at the beginning of
the video now this isn't actually on the
talking points but I believe what is
perhaps the biggest testament to glasses
USA is that this is my second pair of
sunglasses from them a few months ago I
lost a pair while I was on holiday and
by lost I mean I literally flushed them
down the toilet by accident I really
couldn't be making this stuff up and I
had such a good experience with glasses
USA that I just went on the internet and
bought the same identical pair they
already had my prescription I just
plugged it in and I bought a new pair
that's exactly the same I think that
really says a lot about how great it is
you can also try them on online with a
virtual mirror and the best thing of all
it's super affordable glasses USA they
cut out the middleman giving you
prescription glasses at up to 70% off
retail and frames and lenses they start
at just $30 plus you buy quality lenses
they're every good as bit as my old
glasses that I had ages ago they were
overpriced and just not as good and if
you're not happy you can just send them
back there's a hundred percent
money-back guarantee you can check out
glasses usa.com in the link below and
get a special deal on your first pair
and let's get back to Gandhi and his non
glasses USA specs
[Music]
Gandhi was surprised to receive a hero's
welcome back to India his efforts on
behalf of South African Indians had been
well reported over the years an indian
poet referred to him as Mahatma meaning
great soul and the name took hold as a
sign of respect
the shy young man who had left in 1893
returned in 1915 as a leader and he was
a leader with a mission and that of
course was Indian self-rule Gandhi also
challenged his own people to look at the
unfair treatment within their own
culture he challenged the caste system
and especially the terrible treatments
of the lowest class known as The
Untouchables he established a said
gareja settlements in which the people
spun yarn and farmed fruit trees Gandhi
accepted Untouchables into this
community and taught the local peasants
proper hygiene and encouraged factory
workers to wage peaceful strikes against
their unfair working conditions despite
his belief in non-violence Gandhi did
support the British war effort during
World War one at the war's end the
government passed an act making it
illegal for any group to organize in
opposition to the government Gandhi
called for a mass strike to protest the
Lawrence for one day the whole of India
came to a standstill it was clear
evidence of the power that Gandhi was
able to wield yet when reports filtered
in that some Indians had resorted to
violence on the day of peaceful protest
he was bitterly disappointed he knew at
that point that his people as a whole
were not ready for satyagraha now the
British were concerned that there would
be further outbreaks of violence and so
a law was passed banning any gatherings
of Indians in the city of Amritsar one
of the places where violence had
occurred the following day was the
beginning of the religious new year
about 10,000 people gathered in the town
square they had not yet heard the news
of the ban as they were peacefully
listening to a speech 90 soldiers and
two armored cars turned up they blocked
off the only exit and proceeded too far
their weapons into the unarmed crowd of
men women and children 379 people were
killed that day with more than a
thousand being wounded
[Music]
in 1920 Gandhi became the leader of the
Indian National Congress advocating his
nonviolent resistance and instituting
strikes and boycotts to bring pressure
on the system
Gandhi told the people to boycott
British cloth and spin their own he
vowed to spend time spinning every day
and took to wearing clothing made of
hand spun cloth he made the spinning
wheel a national symbol of Indian
independence Gandhi traveled throughout
the massive countryside going mostly on
foot he never - with the downtrodden in
their makeshift dwellings and listened
to their problems to them he was a
saintly figure and they referred to him
as Babel meaning father in March 1922
Gandhi was arrested for sedition the
trial gave him the platform to expound
upon the unfair treatment of Indians and
his refusal to cooperate with unjust
laws pleading guilty he was sentenced to
six years imprisonment gandhi though he
was not deterred using his time of
confinement of read and study after two
years he was released his focus was now
on creating harmony between Hindus and
Muslims for centuries the two groups had
been at loggerheads with one another
with violent clashes often breaking out
Gandhi saw that independence would be
impossible without unity and he was
determined to bring these two groups
together
Gandhi undertook a hunger fast as a tool
to bring the Hindus and the Muslims
together for three weeks he only drank
water as their Babu grew weaker by the
day the Hindus and Muslims finally
agreed to put aside their differences in
order to stop his suffering
on March the 12th 1930 Gandhi began a
month-long track from his ashram in
under about to the sea hundreds and then
thousands of followers of all religions
and carson's joins him along the way
news of the March a filled papers around
the world the British had long imposed a
law making it illegal for anyone to make
salt from seawater in India as a result
they were able to make huge profits from
their salt tax 24 days after setting out
on his march to the sea Gandhi arrived
at dandy on the gulf coast of Cambay the
following morning Gandhi walked out into
the sea water to bathe on his return he
picked up a handful of salt in defiance
of the salt act this act was a signal
for his countrymen and up and down
India's coastline thousands of others
began collecting seawater
in order to make and sell salt many were
arrested including Gandhi who was thrown
in prison for a second time yet the
British could not silence Mahatma
officials now realize that this man held
a powerful sway over the masses he
simply could not be ignored any longer
furthermore the British government both
in India and at home were being
pressured by other governments to
release Gandhi from jail finally the
British Viceroy in India Lord Irwin met
with Gandhi after lengthy discussion
they came to a truce Gandhi would call
off the demonstrations the prisoners
would all be released and Indians would
be allowed to make their own salt in
1931 Gandhi traveled to London to
represent the Indian National Congress
at an international roundtable
conference he called for Indian
independence from Britain he keep
complete independent net we want rather
than mix with the other delegates in
their 5-star hotels Gandhi stayed with
an old friend and spent his days walking
around the slums dressed in his
traditional homespun kadhi and his
sandals he was by now the famous
international figure and newsreels of
his visit were shown in movie theaters
all around the world
[Music]
shortly after returning to India Gandhi
was again arrested for inciting civil
disobedience while he was in prison
the British government passed a law that
discriminated against the untouchables
in court proceedings
Gandhi was infuriated and announced that
he would not eat until this law was
revoked fearing that his death would
create a martyrdom that would doom them
in the eyes of the world the authorities
caved in and the law was rescinded when
Britain declared war on Germany in 1939
Gandhi told the authorities that Indians
would only join the war effort if they
were promised their independence three
years later he started a quit India
movement as always he planned for the
campaign to be nonviolent but things
soon got out of hands and riots broke
out across the country the authorities
blamed Gandhi and once more he was
thrown in jail his beloved wife Kasturba
was also imprisoned at this time indeed
she soon became ill dying in custody On
February the 22nd 1944 following his
wife's death Gandhi grew weak with
malaria the authorities agreed to
release him in May of 1944 and he went
to Bombay to recover and recuperate the
end of World War two saw a Great Britain
on its knees though victorious it had
spent exorbitant amounts in the war
effort and now no longer had the
resources to maintain its rule within
India with little choice in the matter
Britain offered India its independence
it was the grand victory that Gandhi had
been fighting for for the past 30 years
even though the nation was now free to
rule itself India was still plagued with
deep division between Hindus and Muslims
the only solution seemed to be to divide
the country up into Hindu India and
Muslim Pakistan this was a move that was
greatly displeased to Gandhi who longed
the unity between these two groups in
the weeks following the creation of
Pakistan there were violent clashes
between Muslims and Hindus up and down
the country
Masek has occurred throughout 1947 with
both sides being equally responsible for
the bloodshed hundreds of thousands of
people died and there were riots in most
of the major cities On January the 13th
of 1948 the 78 year old Gandhi began a
fast in order to get the madness to stop
he was so despondent that he refused to
even drink water despite the physical
pain that
still led prayer-meeting from his bed
his words were broadcast around the
entire country five days into his fast
Muslim and Hindu leaders agreed to a
peace accord
[Music]
however Gandhi was still very concerned
about the direction the fledgling nation
was taking the new Prime Minister
Jawaharlal Nehru was constantly at odds
with his deputy Vala PI Patel and Gandhi
counseled both men to make peace on
January the 30th 1948 he was in a
meeting with Patel just after 5:00 p.m.
he came out into the garden of Villa
house in Delhi to offer prayers weakens
from his recent fast he leans on two of
his followers for support as he walked a
crowd of some 500 people were waiting to
greet him as he made his way to the
platform a Hindu extremist angered at
Gandhi's leniency towards the Muslims
stepped forward he bowed before the
Mahatma and then pulled out a pistol and
fired three shots in succession a
point-blank range within half an hour
the last breath of life had seeped out
of his body and the great soul was no
more when he heard the news of Mahatma's
death the Prime Minister stated the
light has gone out of our lives and
there is darkness everywhere
Mohandas Gandhi was a light not just to
the people of India but those of the
entire world his funeral procession
through the streets of Delhi was
attended by more than two million people
and years after his death countless
other millions including a young Baptist
minister from Georgia named Martin
Luther King would find inspiration in
his words and in his legacy so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did do give us a like below and
don't forget to subscribe also check out
glasses USA it's just a great deal
you'll find a link in the description
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]
you